he's Joe Thomas the former Browns
all-pro tackle and a Wisconsin grad Joe
you're a former all-pro tackle you're
not considering coming back are you very
happy with retirement and it
I think the knees are a little too far
gone to make any dreams of coming back
and playing well I was one I was being
serious here that you see what's
happening with Cleveland and how hard is
it to look at what's happening in
Cleveland and you went through the tough
years the lean years there with your
career you know any any thoughts like
mentally that you go and I'd like to
come back or I'd love to try to come
back well certainly I wish my career had
more wins than the losses that I was
able to accumulate and obviously it
looks like they're gonna go on a nice
run here they put together a heck of a
team but it's funny I think in my head I
just so certain that I can't do it
anymore
and due to the lack of cartilage and the
pain and suffering that I went through
my last few years just trying to get
ready on Sundays there's nothing in my
mind that says hey maybe if I do this or
that I could get out there and do it I
just know I just don't have anything
left
do you miss hitting people I don't miss
getting it I know that much I'm not sure
I was hitting many people towards the
end of my career anyway I was just
trying to absorb them and get in their
way
for a few seconds so the quarterback
football how much weight have you lost I
would say from my last I'm probably down
about 50 pounds but I surely on in my
career 2012-13 I was pretty heavy I was
like 325 so from that point I'm down
almost 75 but do you get into this mode
that like food is not there to enjoy
like its fuel like I have to eat this
amount not that I want to eat this
amount
yeah I mean that weight was when I was
playing my career I was always sort of
an undersized tackle that had to eat a
lot I mean every meal I had to walk away
feeling like I was going to throw up
just in order to keep enough weight on
so that the coaches weren't yelling at
me on Monday morning so it was always a
struggle I think it became mentally
taxing because every two hours if I
wasn't sitting down and shoving my face
full of bad sugar and carbs and
everything you can imagine I was I would
get stressed out about it because I
would lose weight so quickly when I
would miss a meal that it would it would
be on my mind constantly what was the
bad food that you were shoving into your
mouth well every meal had to have just
an overwhelming amount of carbohydrates
pasta with plenty of dessert which you
know now sounds pretty nice but it also
made my body kind of feel crappy I
always had lots of heartburn and lots of
joint pain from all the sugar and stuff
that I was in taking during my career
well so fight like pizza cookies like
that you you could eat it right yeah
example you know eating a nice normal
meal of an entire plate of lasagna but
then for dessert you need a couple
cookie but that wasn't it then before
bed I would actually go downstairs and
I'd usually pour myself nice 20 or 30
ounce glass a whole milk and then about
a pint of ice cream and then I'd washed
it down with some casein protein before
bed now is really just to maintain my
weight that was about all I had to do
what if you had a maximum weight that
you could that you could weigh in the
NFL just just to maybe encourage guys to
get healthier to be healthier what do
you think about that I'm not sure that
would work it's funny because it seems
like about half the guys that I played
with on the offensive defensive line
were always really struggling and
working hard to gain weight to be able
to get up to that three
pounds or wherever the coach is one of
them and then the other half of the guys
were really struggling hard and you know
we're eating three salads a day just to
get under 325 or 330 so I guess it all
kind of depended on the type of person
you are but you look back in the 80s I
mean there was hardly anybody over 300
pound the N or now it's it's most of the
linemen shoot if you're not 300 pounds
you're under sized uh be put on your
analyst hat here not the former Browns
all-pro tackle here you look at the
brown what what's your biggest concern
about the Browns next season well I
think the big concern going in is just
expectations right the Browns team
hasn't dealt with such an off season of
adulation like they've had right now and
so how does this team handle that I mean
a lot of these guys are young and
they're new and so they haven't been
around for the the decades of losing and
some of the other times when there were
some expectations but I mean there's
legitimate hope that this is a Super
Bowl contender and there's a lot of
people are going to be picking them to
win the AFC North myself included and so
I think just as a young team how do you
handle those heightened expectations how
do you handle that anticipation that
they are going to be good because
they're not sneaking up on anybody
anymore man they won seven games last
year and I think people were a little
surprised by that but they're not
surprising anybody anymore so how do
they handle that how do they put their
nose to the grindstone and go to work
this offseason you got a chance for the
Monday Night Football booth nobody's
been talking to me directly and I'm not
sure I'm ready for that I'm not sure I'm
excited to step into Jason Wynn's shoes
it looks like he didn't have a lot of
fun last year and I'm looking for
something that's fun well do you think
that's a cautionary I mean you being
serious that you saw what happened to
Witten and you're like you know I've
never called a game and to be thrown in
there and now you're following up Witten
so they're they're expecting something
from that person who steps in that booth
yeah you know I auditioned for it last
year and coming out of the audition
after you kind of ask the questions
about alright you know what's it like if
you're doing this you know what's the
preparation like what's the travel like
and you start hearing about it and it's
like wow that's a lot more work than I
did during my career you know when
you're traveling Friday to Tuesday for
20 straight weeks and the two days
you're home you're largely kind of
preparing and especially for somebody
like me who's never called a game I got
a lot of work to do right as an analyst
as somebody that does
you know pregame or you're talking about
the game on one of the highlight shows
that's easy stuff you know that stuff
that you've done throughout your career
because you're just answering questions
from you know what you were used to
doing during your career after games but
when you're calling a game that's a
whole different am on so I'd have a lot
to learn it would be it would be a lot
more work than I'm looking for right now
I'm looking for something pretty easy
dan I don't want to work too hard my
first few years in retirement I respect
that your reaction when you saw Johnny
manziel's now a member of the IAF's
Memphis Express yeah it's interesting
I'm curious to see where that career is
gonna lead him and you know it'll be
interesting to kind of fall on that path
and see what happens you didn't have to
wait a minute
anytime much to say about that in
Chicago and certainly wish him the best
but it won't be the first thing that
shows up on my timeline that's for sure
you got your bracket you're the first
one to turn in your bracket in the
celebrity bracket challenge you got Duke
Gonzaga
Tennessee and Kentucky and Duke winning
the national title how much college
basketball do you watch you you know to
be honest I follow the Badgers and watch
some of the Big Ten stuff and then other
than that I don't really pay much
attention until the tournament rolls
around so uh
timing right now that I'm on your show
talking yes well because I am kind of
the resident expert well we're gonna
find out great to talk to you and we
will keep an eye on those brackets
thanks for joining us as always Joe damn
that's a Joe Thomas former Cleveland
Browns offensive line for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]